[MUSIC PLAYING]
KRISTIN NICHOLAS: Hi, everybody.
I made you a Google Doodle.
And it's all patterned.
I grew up in a family of five
girls in northern New Jersey,
and textiles and fabrics
were always around.
I learned to sew when
I was nine, and stitch.
My grandmother was a
quilter, embroiderer.
And I really got
interested in it,
and I actually went to school
for textiles and clothing.
And then I got a master's in it.
And for 16 years I worked
as a creative director
at a yarn company.
And then I had my
daughter, who's here,
and I decided to go freelance.
And I've written
12 books so far.
This is my latest,
"Crafting a Patterned Home".
So I've got a little bit
of stuff that previews.
This is our house.
It's a 1751 farmhouse.
And it's white on the
outside, and you can't really
tell what's inside it.
Here it is in the snow.
And we have a sheep farm.
We have about 300 sheep,
and my husband is a farmer.
He grew up on a farm.
And so we sell our lamb at
farmers' markets and wholesale
a little bit.
So I'm always shuffling
around frozen meat.
And so the sheep graze.
They keep the land down.
It was an old,
abandoned apple orchard.
So here's in the fall.
It's incredibly beautiful.
I don't know if anybody's
been to western Mass,
but it's really
pretty out there.
This is my pottery shed.
This is actually part
of the book project.
And here's some sunflowers.
I love sunflowers.
I love all kinds of
nature and flowers.
I grow a lot of flowers, and
they're a big part of my work.
Zinnias, my favorites.
And just the leaves,
all the motion.
You can get ideas for
patterns from that.
The vines going around.
Watering can with that
beautiful heart-shaped leaf.
You're going to see
that a little later.
Hydrangeas.
Beautiful pinks, browns,
greens, chartreuses.
More zinnias.
And for a while there, we grew
up about an acre of sunflowers,
and this is them.
We've scaled a little
bit back because we've
gone more into the
sheep, but this is them.
And I still do a big garden,
half a garden of sunflowers.
I just love the shapes.
And you guys probably
know what the name is
about how the seeds go around.
I have no clue.
I just know it's pretty.
And here's some sheep,
lambs on pasture.
More sheep.
This is an abandoned
apple orchard.
Pretty, pretty colors here.
That stuff, it's a weed,
but it's so pretty.
So I also have
collected textiles
for years and years and years.
I started when I found a
piece when I was in college,
and it was my first
piece I bought.
I can remember it
was back in the '70s,
and it was right
before Afghanistan
was going to be taken over.
And I was like, I got
to get a piece of this.
So I still have that
piece of fabric.
And this is suzani,
which is from Uzbekistan.
I love this motif.
It's all embroidered, if you can
believe it, all hand-stitched.
So I find the connection between
somebody hand stitching that
and then me using it as a motif
in my designs as a cool thing
to do.
So I do a lot of computer
stuff with digital art
and use these designs.
There's my sunflowers.
And you're going to see more of
this room a little bit later.
Those walls are
all hand-painted.
I hand painted them.
And that's a collection
of cloisonne,
which is either
from Japan or China,
and it's enamel on brass.
Beautiful colors you can get.
So I have quite a bit of that.
I love all the designs on it.
This is an old
antique Italian urn
with dahlias in the background.
And you can see the other
piece of textile fabric
on the bottom, and
more cloisonne.
So I find I can take a
bunch of flowers and some
of these beautiful objects
I have and some fabrics,
and I can get a design
idea just by placing
those things together and
then taking a photo of it.
And I can either paint
a picture off of it,
or maybe figure out
how to take two motifs
and match them together
or get color ideas.
And the walls there
are stenciled.
I hand stenciled them.
Here's a bunch of
inspiration pictures.
I'm going to go kind of fast
because I got a lot of them.
This is from Portugal, ceramics.
This is a mola from Panama.
Old carpet.
Some transferware with
flowers and books that I think
is from India.
Correct me if I'm
wrong if anybody knows.
This is also from India.
This is incredible.
Every single stitch in
there is embroidered
to make those motifs.
I mean, it's just unbelievable.
This is from Uzbekistan,
beautiful border treatment.
This is an old sleeve from--
I can't remember where
because I really don't know.
But see the moths have
eaten a little bit of it?
But I just love the motif
and the border treatment.
And then the piece
of felt up the right
that's all kind of moth eaten.
Pretty idea.
This is a Peruvian piece.
This is from India,
a block print.
I'm crazy over these things.
That's another part of that.
This is crewel work,
all stitched from India.
This, I have no idea
where it came from,
but it's all inlaid, so it's
all carved and then inlaid.
And these are some
saris from India.
So isn't that cool how
they've got the paisley design
at the bottom and then
mixed with the plaid,
and then the medallion
piece on the top?
You can take all these
ideas and then turn them
into something of your own.
This is a piece of ikat fabric.
That's another sari with
all kinds of fun sequins.
Another piece from India with
mirrors, all embroidered.
Another piece from India.
This is from Uzbekistan.
That's the back.
Lots of times these things are
so pretty in the back, too.
More from India.
That's from Africa.
It's a piece of kente cloth.
And that's a piece
of needlepoint.
I don't know where it's from.
From India, more from
India, Uzbekistan.
India.
And so we have a lot of
creatures at our farm.
Now I'm going to tell you
a little bit about that.
That's Annika the cat.
And that is--
I don't even know what
name she was because we
have a litters of kittens.
And she just happened to be
doing that for the photo shoot,
and it was like oh my goodness,
stripes on pattern on pattern.
How fabulous is that?
And this, a litter of kittens
with a beautiful rug behind it
and crewel work.
That's Paisley, one
of our sheep dogs,
Border Collie to
round up the sheep.
That's Kate.
These are two Great
Pyrenees guard dogs.
They are Bo and Sadie and
they keep the coyotes away.
But they're
sweethearts to people.
And there's some
more sheep, chickens.
That's the name of our farm.
And that's moving them.
You have to move them,
and there's a lot of them.
And so we do it along the road.
And this is lambing season.
That's probably 10 minutes old.
They get up in about 15
minutes and they know right
where to go to eat.
It's amazing.
Just born.
Well, you can see the fluid on
her and she's licking it off.
Sometimes I go a little
nuts and dress up my sheep.
So this is a ram.
And I was doing
this photo shoot.
I had this idea to make
a sweater for a lamb.
And I was getting it all
ready, and my husband
said, look over there.
This little sheep was sitting
on top of this 300 pound ram.
It was like oh, so cute.
So this is an image
that I did that's pretty
popular around the internet.
And so this was my 11th book,
"Crafting a Colorful Home".
And now this is
the book I'm here
to talk about called
"Crafting a Patterned Home".
So all these pictures
of these projects
are all things that you guys
can make if you so choose.
Everything's done by hand.
None of the materials
are expensive.
And as long as you get the
idea and get the nerve,
you can decorate your home,
or maybe decorate some fabric,
or do stuff for a
shirt or a tablecloth.
We're going have a
little section on color.
And these are pieces of felt.
I love to play with colors.
And just by rolling
things up, you
can figure out what colors
work well against each other
when you're putting
them together.
And the same thing
you can do with yarn.
And you can do it with paint.
Has everybody seen
a color wheel?
Pretty much you learned
it when you were a kid.
But I use this a lot.
I use it intuitively.
I call it a rainbow
in the round.
So as you can see, it
goes all the way around.
It has 12 slices.
And if you look opposite each
other on the color wheel,
those are complementary colors.
If you look next to
each other, those
are called analogous colors.
And I'm going to talk
a lot about that.
So just try to remember.
So here we have
samples that I painted.
All the way to the left
are the analogous colors.
So they're like orange,
yellow, and red orange.
In the center, we've got the
complementary colors, so blue
and violet.
And to the right
we have something
that I call tonal colors.
So it's like shades of blue.
And so you can think about
what you like the best
and use that in your
home in different places,
depending on the
mood you want to get.
This is another good
way to work with color
is have just a piece of
paper in the background,
and then just get a
flower or something
and see how the colors
work against each other.
So this is what I call
analogous because they're all
sort of related.
It goes from the
chartreuse to the yellow
and then to the orange.
And this is getting
a little bit away
from that because it's got
the hot pink background.
But you can see the same
flowers, how different they're
starting to look.
This is on blue, on a brighter
blue, so this is complementary.
You see how they're popping?
And then that's a little bit
more subdued, bluish gray.
And here it is in real life.
This is a complementary color
combination in fabulous yellow,
purple, green.
And here it is on furniture.
This is our house.
And so I use a lot of
pattern in the house.
It has, actually,
very light gray walls.
And then I mix
fabrics, colors, and--
whoops, there we go--
pottery, all these
things with it.
So I used the very
light gray wall,
and then brought the patterns
in, first with the pottery
and then with more fabrics.
This is the living room.
So you probably can't
see it, but this
is a tonal living room.
I actually have
chartreuse and gold walls
and mixed with green.
Actually, it's analogous.
But then, by bringing in
all the different patterns
and the different fabrics,
it looks differently.
It starts to become
complementary
because the oranges and
the reds are popping off
the green and the yellow.
And so then you start mixing
all these different patterns
together and you get what I
find very pleasing and cozy
and warm by mixing
all the colors.
There's another view.
Oh.
Did you see the kittens
over there by the door?
And there's a turquoise
wall in the background.
So I chose that color so it
would pop off a little bit
from the rest of the room,
which is sort of gold,
because I wanted
the space to look
different than just putting,
say, a gold wall there.
I wanted to differentiate
that this was a stairway.
This is an analogous
combination.
So you can see the
chartreuse, and then
the green, moss green cabinets.
But you see the red?
That is-- whoops, sorry.
That's a complementary
combination,
and that's popping.
This is just some
artwork I've done.
That's Charlie the cat.
He loves this room.
This is the library TV room.
And I use a lot of
fabrics in here.
And we'll get more
into this later,
but all that painting on the
walls, it's not wallpaper.
Good wallpaper is really, really
expensive to do a room in.
So I couldn't afford
it, so I just said OK,
I'll do it myself.
So I painted the walls
to look like wallpaper.
And it took a couple
days, but it actually
is pretty because there's
all these little different
variations in it where wallpaper
would be screen printed
and just look pretty flat.
OK.
We're going to talk
about some patterns.
So does anybody
think about patterns?
Patterns, to me, are like so--
I just love them.
They're so inspirational.
They just make me feel happy.
The simplest one is a polka dot.
You guys all did polka
dots when you were kids,
and here's different
bunches of polka dots.
So we've got little pin dots,
bigger dots, random spaced,
spaced out, and
alternating stripes.
Next thing.
Simple stripe, but
you can move on
and keep changing the stripes.
So you see all the
variations you can do?
Just hand drawn.
And then if you take a stripe
and you turn it on its side,
you've got a plaid or a check.
So this is just a natural
progression of patterns
and how you can make them.
And you can see all the
different variations
you can get.
If you take it and twist
it on the diagonal,
twist it 45 degrees,
you've got a diagonal.
And then if you start
cutting them into segments
and you start flipping them
around, you've got chevrons,
and you've got a trellis design.
And so these are
all motifs that are
used in all kinds of
wallpapers and fabrics.
I mean, we look around.
This room is awesome.
You've got all these gorgeous
plaid fabrics, which--
it's a pattern, but there's
so many different variations.
This next section,
this is geometrics.
So they're squares
and rectangles,
putting them in between
stripes and you make a pattern.
More geometric circles,
hexagons, triangles, diamonds,
ovals.
So you see how
there's a lot that you
can do with simple
motifs to make a pattern.
And then these are
called organic motifs.
And they're more
round and organic--
tulips, hearts, paisleys, one
of my favorite things, flowers.
And here we have organic
motifs, more in striped patterns
and borders, combining them.
And this is called
a figurative motif.
And that would be something if
you see Christmas or Halloween
wallpaper, they
take little objects
and make patterns out of them.
Here, this is how different
patterns are made.
We can have a lot of white
space in the background,
and this is very dots on dots.
Then we can have a
bigger dot, and so you
have a whole different
feeling from the dots when
you change the sizes
and change the backdrop.
Now here we can have them
so they're spaced out
and you get a random pattern.
But you've still
got the coverage
on the one on the
right, and the other one
is very open and loose.
And it gives a
different feeling.
It'll give a different feeling
to a fabric, to a room.
This is pattern repeats.
You can see a straight repeat
up on the left, top left.
And if you move to the right,
you can see a brick repeat,
looks like a brick pattern that
you see all the time in Boston.
To the left on the bottom,
that's called a half drop,
so the circles move down a half.
And then we have
a random repeat.
So that's basically fabric
design and wallpaper design.
That's what you do.
And if you do it on
a computer, you just
move it with numbers, which
is what I do a lot of.
This piece of fabric,
I actually started out
designing it by hand, and then
I brought it into Illustrator
and made it into
the pattern and had
the slipcover made for that.
And here's some more pottery.
I made a bunch of that pottery.
I do that more free form.
There's some antique
stuff in there too.
Here's a thing on where
could we get ideas.
This is my favorite thing.
Books, I know.
I go on Google, too.
But I find like just having the
physical thing in front of me
is easier for me to work from.
I know a lot of
people use Pinterest.
I have a very slow
connection where I live.
So I tend to just go old school.
But you can see
such great things.
I also like to visit
a lot of art museums,
and I have a lot of art books.
And I find the color
inspiration from there.
And there's another, just
doodling, figuring things out,
and then I painted the
table underneath there.
So these are projects
for my new book.
It's all real free form.
I actually used my fingers
to paint a lot with,
put the stripes on in different
colors and just splodge things
with my fingers, and
played with the colors.
There's the top of the table.
And I actually made that just
by taking plates and drawing
around them and figuring out the
spaces on the top of the table.
Sometimes I cut
things out of paper,
just like folding them to
get the shape that way.
And then I trace
around it with a pencil
and I paint it in by hand.
And that took less than a day.
It's pretty quick.
This is an embroidered piece
that I actually printed.
And I don't know if you saw
it on the table outside,
but I use these things.
It's kids' fun foam.
And I print with kids' fun
foam on insulation board.
And let's see.
This is that.
And it's all embroidered.
And if somebody wants to
come up here and take these,
I'm happy to pass them around.
And you can see the
embroidery around it.
The embroidery is adding
more colors to it.
Now so in this picture
what we did was,
we didn't want it
to be boring, so we
put in the pops of the color.
And I look at this room
that you guys are in,
and I'm looking
around, and there's
a lot of browns and tans.
But then they put
in pops of color.
They put the red
and the chartreuse,
and that's what's making
the room super fun.
And so when you're
making pictures,
you have to do that also.
And see how we used the pops
of color for the plates.
And the idea for this
one is I wanted something
that sort of was
mid-century modern looking,
so I did these stripes and
spaced them apart three inches
and did different colors.
But the colors are like
teal, dark teal, lupin blue,
and a brown.
It gives that sort of
mid-century modern vibe, which
doesn't really go
in my house, but you
can sort of mix everything
together and make it look good.
But then we used the
pop of the colors
of the chairs and
the plates to make
the picture look interesting.
Here what we've done
is these are napkins.
So I did blue with brown
on top, printed them,
and they actually
just use latex paint.
All the directions
are in my book.
And just did-- had
fun with some spacing.
So there's one spacing.
Here is a different
kind of spacing.
And here is a different
So I started with one stripe
and then kept filling the holes.
So a lot of this
is playing around.
Not everything is successful,
but paint is cheap.
And you can just
slap it on the wall.
You don't like it,
just change it.
And the way this
picture is working
is the complementary
combination.
See how it's orange and blue?
And that's what's making
that just pop and look vivid.
There's those patterns.
These are plates that
are ceramic plates.
And for this book,
I wanted to make
things that were
approachable for people
that maybe don't have as
much experience as I do.
So I started with
polka dots, and I
figured anybody can put
a polka dot on a plate.
And then I moved from
the simple polka dot,
started changing up the sizes
on the polka dots, putting rims
around them, and then the
big concentric circle one.
And as you can see,
it's off centered,
and that makes it a little
bit more A, easy to do,
and B, interesting.
And then my plan was
I had this tablecloth.
So I thought, OK I'll
put the white plates
with the blue trim
on this tablecloth,
and it would look really good.
And I think it does.
This is simple.
These are stripes, and
what I did here was I
just added a little
bit of stitching.
And if you can see
the color on these,
they were white, and a
light teal and a chartreuse.
And by picking a complementary
color and drawing lines,
I just put stitches up it.
And it's a nice
present, very easy
to do if you want
to relax at night.
And let's see.
There's a close-up of that.
I've got this afghan here.
So this is crocheted.
And I don't know if anybody
knows how to crochet,
but maybe your grandma does. ,
And my idea with this one was
to make it more modern.
So I just chose two colors.
And I actually drew
it out on my computer,
fooled around with
the color placement
and how big I wanted these
hexagons, or hexagons to be.
And then I wrote up the pattern.
And they're pieces that
are then sewn together.
This is not in the book,
but this is also hexagons.
And it's kind of crazy,
but really super fun.
And people love this afghan.
It's a great way to get rid
of things, old bits of yarn
and everything.
Now this next slide, this
has been a dream of mine,
to have a paisley chair to
sit in to knit at night.
I know.
I dream about these things.
So the fabric is all
hand-printed with this stamp,
nine yards.
But the cool thing
about this is--
I'm going to pass these around.
These are the remnants from it.
If you look at them, you can
see how it's not exactly even,
but that's what makes
it more interesting.
And so this is one colorway.
It actually has three
different colorways on it.
That's the bottom.
And here, David, you
want to pass that?
DAVID: Sure thing.
KRISTIN NICHOLAS:
And just so you
see a difference, this winter I
translated a lot of the designs
from the book that I had hand
printed in the digital files,
and I had them digital printed.
So do you see the difference?
See this top one here?
So if it's printed, it looks
sort of flat and uninteresting
because it is digital printed.
That, you can see
different bits of texture,
and to me, it looks
more interesting.
This is the wallpaper
that I hand painted.
And I just used FedEx boxes,
and I cut out the motifs,
and I just dropped a plumb
line, started with the cross,
put that on the
wall, painted it red,
and then kept laying the motifs
on and adding more colors in.
And then I got
tired of that, and I
said, OK, I'm going to
switch it up a little bit.
So I had a small space
between the windows,
so I took the square idea,
turned it on its side,
made it a diagonal, and made
almost like an argyle tile
design, and then
painted some vases
with flowers on top of it.
And you can see the fabrics
that I've used on the top.
Those are things
that you saw earlier.
They're from Uzbekistan,
the embroidered pieces.
In the past I've been
known for knitting,
so I had to put a
knitting thing in.
And that is-- let's see.
Right here, OK.
Pillow that's not sewed,
it travels better.
So it's just you follow a chart.
Is anybody a knitter here?
Oh, there we go.
OK, good.
So you guys know this.
And follow the chart.
And then these little bits are
added on later in embroidery.
Yeah.
Here you can see the chair
with the different colors.
So the khaki and the red.
And on the side I used
a yellow just for fun.
And most people aren't
even going to see this.
But for me it's fun.
OK.
Upstairs in the bathroom I had
yellow walls that were color
washed.
So for this design I made
long, eight-inch stripes
because my ruler
was eight inches.
Lots of times I just do
things that are really easy.
And then I cut this ogee
pattern out and traced around it
with a pencil, and
then just filled it
in with streaky paint.
And this picture
is really popular.
It's been on the
internet a bunch.
And the bathtub, I was
inspired by embroidery.
So I just took some white
paint and just did sort of
like a flower design on it.
It took less than an hour.
And then I put the border on
the bottom on the wood stand.
And you can see that
little sun design,
which I actually got off of
this tile that was on the walls.
I wanted do some things
that were really easy.
This is called combing.
You take a piece of cardboard.
You cut it so it
looks like a comb.
You paint one color
on a piece of wood.
So I painted it blue.
Then I painted it white,
and while it was still wet,
I took the piece of cardboard
that looked like a comb
and just dragged it through
in this kind of swirly design.
So except for the
waiting for it to dry,
this project was probably 40
minutes or something like that
after I got the paint on it.
So I like sunflowers.
So this is the
sunflower bedroom.
I did it in the winter when
it was really, really gray.
And I thought, oh, let's do
some overblown sunflowers.
So I just took a big piece of 18
by 24 paper, folded it in four,
and then just cut
some shapes out.
And I used them as a template,
and I drew with pencil around
and left space for the leaves.
So I painted them all
in a light yellow.
Then I went back and added some
leaves, free form leaves where
it needed to be, so
there was a lot of space
available around the
flowers, and then
put sort of a wash
for the center
and outlined it all
in a dark brown.
And it just makes me happy.
And in one end of the
room, to calm it all down,
I put this pretty spring green
because the maple leaves--
you know that one day
when they come out
and it's just gorgeous?
So that's what this color is.
So in the winter I can look
at that and say, oh yeah,
one day spring will be here.
But it just gives it a nice--
like a break.
And then I put these
antique engravings
on the wall and all the books.
There's another
corner of the room.
That's an oil painting I did,
and also lampshade I painted.
I do a lot of
lampshade paintings.
On the other wall
there's closets,
and I thought,
OK, I need to have
something that's more geometric
to stand off these sunflowers.
So I came up with this
idea of big diamonds.
And I put tape in
a diamond form,
and I just sponged it
with a piece of sponge
to get kind of the mottled edge.
And it's another part
of the room that's
like geometric versus organic.
And as you move around the
room, it has different feelings.
And it all sort
of mixes together.
This is a bedspread that I did.
It's quilting, because this book
is for all kinds of crafters.
So this is pieced.
And I used an idea-- the Amish
people are incredible quilters,
and way back when they
used to do a lot of stuff
with these beautiful
bright colors of wool.
And this was inspired off
that, very simple shapes.
The back of it,
this is a linocut
that I carved into Speedy
Carve, it's called,
so I used a carving knife.
And I printed it in black
and then I scanned it.
Then I brought it
into Illustrator.
And then I made the
fabric for the backing
and mixed up all the
different colors.
So you don't really
see it, but it's
a way you can add
little bits of surprises
and take these
hand painting ideas
and put them into use
in the computer world.
There's a company
called Spoon Flower
that's out of North Carolina.
I don't know if
you know about it.
But that's where I get
this stuff printed.
And then another thing, for
a little bit of visual rest,
is these giant polka
dots that were hand
printed on a piece of linen.
And I called this--
I was thinking about
big and little dots,
so I did these
giant dots and then
put French knots, which is
an embroidery technique,
around it in a different
color, and I backed it
in this fun color.
So you know, you can do this
stuff at night when you're, I
don't know, trying to cool down.
This is the dining room.
This is all painted walls,
and then down below it's
a plaid design.
More of the dining room
with my oil paintings
and mixing the fabrics in.
These are tiles that I actually
painted and glazed and fired
and put on a piece
of cement board
and mounted them into the
wall onto the fireplace.
And these are some
projects outside.
You know she sheds are a term?
I don't know if anybody
has heard about it.
But it's a term so
these are she sheds,
and these have vines and a fun
painted rug and printed fabric.
And this is my pottery shed.
So I used vinyl VCT tiles on
the floors in bright colors.
And there's the floor
and the cat, Charlie.
And I just did this around the
edges, stamped with sponges.
And I used different
colors all the way
around the room for more fun
because it doesn't really
have to match.
And that's a
hand-printed linocut.
And there's some of my pottery.
More greenware patterns.
And this is a sourcebook I got.
I don't know where it's from.
I can't understand it.
It's got some kind
of weird writing.
But I love that.
This was probably given
as a guide for people
to do embroidery way
back when somewhere.
This is a lamp from Home Depot.
I spray painted it and
then put squiggles on it.
And that's the outside.
I did a little bit of
mural and-- oh, more.
OK.
There's that leaf I showed
you in the very beginning,
the morning glory leaf, with
others, and a picnic down
in the orchard with
different projects.
This is the last bit.
This is a cocktail
hour under the pergola.
And I did this big,
big, oversized kind
of Matisse-inspired
circular tabletop.
And I free-handed
the leaf design,
and then I mixed it with
some more gridded designs
and then these napkins that
are just all hand-painted.
And they're scattered
around the room.
They're hand-painted stripes.
So does anybody
have any questions?
AUDIENCE: So what I like about
this photo is that the table is
really sort of free form,
but then the photos in the,
I guess prints in the
background are very orderly.
And so the balance or
contrast there is really nice.
How do you think about
balancing that, and having
some things that
are sort of more
structured and formulaic
with some things that are
a little bit more free form?
KRISTIN NICHOLAS: It's a mix.
So I usually will
start with a fabric,
and then have some
kind of busy fabric.
Say if I'm doing a room, and
that will be the color idea.
And then I pick a
backdrop and then
just keep adding things in.
This table and the rug, the
table is organic, right?
The pictures on the
wall are very square,
but when you get up
close, they're not.
They're also little pictures.
And then the rug is a base.
And a lot of this is
done in photography.
So when you're photographing
projects like I do,
you have to make the
picture look good.
So you're looking
through the viewfinder
and balancing it all
out, making a mix.
And sometimes you might
move a set all the way
across the room to
a different color.
So that rug is usually
not under that table,
but it made the
picture work good.
And it's just trial and
error and experience.
I can't tell you
the magic formula.
I've been doing
this for so long.
But anyway, I don't
know if I helped you.
AUDIENCE: So a first question
is when you painted the wall
with the red crosses
and stuff, did you
use the stencils for that?
KRISTIN NICHOLAS: No, I used
FedEx boxes because I had them.
They're good, stiff cardboard,
so I cut the shapes out of them
and traced around it just
with a leaded pencil,
and then filled it
in with a paintbrush.
AUDIENCE: I see.
KRISTIN NICHOLAS: I
don't like stenciling.
You have to be really neat,
and I'm not very neat.
If you put the
plastic stencil on,
sometimes it seeps underneath.
You have to clean it off.
It's just this is faster for me.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Well, it looked perfect.
KRISTIN NICHOLAS: And
if I stenciled it,
it wouldn't have been perfect.
It would have been a hassle.
AUDIENCE: Probably.
And second question is, you
said you print your fabrics.
So what is the technique?
How do you print them?
I know you print them
digitally, but when
you do it at home and on
your own, how do you do that?
KRISTIN NICHOLAS:
I have an iPad Pro
and I use a program called
Procreate, which is $9.99.
And I have an Apple Pencil
and I just start drawing.
And I use the different brushes.
I get a design, like a motif
that I'm interested in,
and then I bring it into
Illustrator, do Live Trace,
and start building
files in Illustrator,
whether I want a straight
repeat, a half drop, a brick,
just start fooling
around with it.
So it's sort of a combination.
Sometimes I'll actually
draw something.
Or these things
that I showed you I
actually printed them,
scanned them, and then
brought them into Illustrator.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So do you do hand
print them by yourself,
or it's all through Illustrator?
KRISTIN NICHOLAS:
That digital printing,
I send it to Spoon
Flower, send them a file,
and it comes in two weeks.
And you can get a yard.
You can actually
get a half a yard.
It's amazing what
you can do now.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's great.
KRISTIN NICHOLAS: Yeah.
So I'm really
interested in that now.
It's cool.
You can reach more people.
So I'm hoping that
people will really
want to try some of this
stuff by hand because it's
really, really easy and
doesn't take much time.
But it's A, finding the time,
B, getting the supplies, which
I've tried to make things that
you have around your house,
and then just doing it,
getting the nerve to do it.
That, I find, is most
people's problem.
They don't have the nerve.
So that's why I help people.
I teach classes and
help them get over
their fear of sticking
a stamp onto fabric.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and it's
great to actually see
don't be afraid of color
and patterns together.
So that was really nice
to see because we tend
to go in the same direction.
KRISTIN NICHOLAS:
And if you look
at the interior decorating
magazines, you open them up,
oh my god, they're all
white and gray and beige.
And I barely ever
seen anything that I'm
interested in because
it's just all safe.
And I think people are
really afraid of color
and putting it together.
But it doesn't take
a lot to do it.
It's just getting the nerve up.
And maybe start on a small
space like a bathroom.
If you do a big
patterned wallpaper
or mural in a bathroom
so it's real big scale,
it can look fabulous.
And try it that way
and get used to it.
I also hear about a lot
of partners, you know,
husband likes this,
the wife doesn't.
And that's the stumbling block.
My husband loves everything.
He's fine with it.
AUDIENCE: Good for you.
KRISTIN NICHOLAS: I'm lucky.
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious about
the relationship between--
you showed many rooms
where everything's
in kind of a fun harmony.
And so the first
thought I was going
to ask was, oh, did
you start with nothing
and then build all
this room at once?
And it's like, no, OK.
So if you've got a room that
already has a direction it's
going, I can sort of
imagine how you might say,
OK, this is a piece that
would go well there.
But suppose you are
moving into a place
that's all white and gray--
KRISTIN NICHOLAS: Yes, which
is all builder's houses.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
How do you get started on--
where would you start?
How would you start building
the intuitions and the this
is the way this is
going to fit together?
KRISTIN NICHOLAS:
Well, I suggest
you get some of those
decorating magazines
that I just said are
all white and beige,
and start ripping pages
out that you like.
Or go on Pinterest if you want,
and just start building a file.
And you're going to
see a pattern coming
through to what you like.
And then pick the
favorite thing,
start with one room,
maybe a bedroom
because nobody will see it,
and start decorating and seeing
what happens, seeing how you do.
So that would be one room,
also, it's away from people.
And then maybe do the
bathroom next door.
And start working
it so that each room
goes along and starts
being filled up
with more and more color.
And you will find
your own theme.
You'll find your own thing
for sure because people do.
They have things that
they like, and then they
can put them in their
houses, colors that they like
and put them in their houses.
You can do it.
You can, I promise you.
It's just A, getting the nerve.
OK.
Well, thank you so
much for having me.
I hope you can think
more about using color
in your home and your
wardrobe or whatever you do.
And also start looking around.
I took a little walk through,
and I can't believe this space.
They've got such
fantastic colors
and all kinds of design ideas.
And so maybe you'll
walk to the Marriott
and see some cool
kind of carpet.
And just start bringing
more pattern into your life
because it's happy.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.